hi hi hey there we are the cost of
fantastic beasts crimes attendant did
you know before he who must not be named
aka Lord Baltimore aka you-know-who
there was the og Dark Wizard you must
not be forgotten you know the name wait
you don't know the name Gellert been
involved sorcerer of pure-blooded
ancestry and cold-blooded vision
honestly not that nice of a guy he's
like the most powerful wizard of all
time on you forgetting someone
ah yes his rivalry with Albus Dumbledore
was legendary
greenwall was like hey kill Vlad saw me
let's kill all the now matches and
Dumbledore was like yo what he tried to
lock him away in Amakusa prison that did
not work now that he's escaped his
legion of followers his crime and you
got the elder one the most powerful wand
of all time so yeah it's not great
he makes Voldemort look like a pygmy
puff and there's only one person who can
stop it
not Dumbledore Newt Scamander
we list the beginning of the first Dark
Lord in fantastic beasts the crimes of
Grindelwald
he knows maybe he's a cool guy pledge to
me your eternal allegiance or die nope
never mind